el asesinato en las últimas horas de un
tercer policía en menos de 23 días
sumerge al gobierno del pre izquierdista
Gabriel boric en una nueva crisis de
seguridad en el país en un momento en
que se vive una gran conmoción en las
calles por el asesinato de este policía
y también en lo que es una de las
mayores preocupaciones de los chilenos
que han visto aumentar el número de
delitos violentos en sus calles en los
últimos meses un tema que es de El mayor
tema de preocupación para el gobierno
esto ha hecho que el gobierno de Gabriel
borics promulgara de forma Exprés este
mismo jueves una ley que fue tramitada
en un tiempo récord de tan solo siete
días en el congreso y cuya redacción
original fue polémica porque modificaba
el uso por parte de las armas por parte
de la policía y las fuerzas armadas en
Casos de legítima defensa esta ley hace
que si ahora usan las armas en defensa
propia no sean suspendidos de empleo y
sueldo como sucedía hasta ahora y no
sean investigados el gobierno o
modificar la ley enviando un estatuto
que todavía está por enviar en el que se
detallará específicamente Cuáles son las
situaciones en las que se considera
defensa propia y el uso de las armas ha
supuesto también la división de la
coalición del gobierno puesto que la
parte más a la izquierda de la prueba de
dignidad se ha mostrado contraria a la
aprobación de esta ley y también ha
manifestado en algunos casos que la va a
llevar al tribunal constitucional esto
en una jornada en la que se promulgan
otras tres leyes en medidas de seguridad
una ley que tipifica el delito de
extorsión y leyes que agravan las penas
por secuestro y también por tenencia de
armas en lugares de Gran concurrencia de
público